So here we are
A thief
one thug
an angry little tree
an evil step-sister
a pirate, an assassin
and most importantly me
You are insufferable
The guardians must be destroyed
SON OF A
That's really bad sign
Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. Awesome news
James Gunn has confirmed he is doing Guardians of the Galaxy 3
and said little bit about where the characters are headed
after Infinity War. He confirmed a little bit about the movie
So, I will explain what is going on. If you are new to the channel, be sure to subscribe
to get everything. I do Marvel videos every week.
The new footage looks great. Just to address that really quick
The abilisk, you get a much better shot of that. Drax is just running right up into it's mouth like open wide
Kevin Feige did this big QnA where he explains that this is really like early in the film
The Guardians are hired by the Sovereign to protect this platform
full of special batteries which power almost their entire civilization
So, it's just meant to be fun, action set piece to open the movie with.
So, it's relatively early in the movie.
We meet Ego the living planet relatively early on too
And he explains the whole reason that the Sovereign
then turn on the guardians and go after them is because
Rocket steals a couple of the batteries
thinking that these people are bunch of douchebags.
They are not gonna miss one or two batteries
So, Ayesha's character from the comics is so insulted by that act
that she declares war on them. So, it's kinda funny that
this big galactic chase to come after them. Fox on the run style - just because they steal a couple of battery from them
But really the big news is James Gunn confirming that he is gonna do Guardians 3
He's been on the fence. He has talked about a Rocket and Groot's spin-off movie
what I think will happen that he will do this third Guardians file
and it will just be a little bit more Rocket and Groot centric whereas
most of the Guardians films tend be centred around Peter Quill and the idea of his family
They will introduce some new characters. But he says very specific things about the future of the characters
in phase 3 through infinity war and where that will leave them in the next film,
it gives you pretty good idea where the characters are headed
So this is directly from his quote that I am reading
Much of the what is happening in MCU for the past 10 years or so has been leading
in a big way to avengers infinity war.
Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 3 will happen after that
It will conclude the story for this iteration of the Guardians of the galaxy
and help catapult both old and new Marvel characters
into the next 10 years or beyond.
So that means it's going to be a big jumping off point for these characters
and jumping on point for the brand new characters.
I know this makes it sounds kind of weird
and it does sound a little all new, all different. Not literally.
If you have read the all new, all different Marvel comics
It kind of went in flames a little bit.
People were going crazy about it. I am not talking about that
I am just talking about infinity war being an opportunity
because of what happens during that story - to wipe the slate clean
and allow the characters to go forward in a fresh new direction
It is just sort of transitional period because Thanos changes the universe
so much with the infinity gauntlet that when you put it back together
It is just story opportunity for the writers, for the producers to change
thing creatively however they want when they are going forward in phase 4.
The other part of James Gunn announcement was this giant superpost
where he professes his love for his characters. He talks about them pretty much in, you know,
that they are all going to survive
Most of them, 99% of them are going to be in infinity war and then they will come back
for the next film. You probably expected that for the main cast
from the first film who are returning like
Drax, Rocket, Groot, Gamora
even Nebula's character who is really cool
in Guardians 2. But, the new character - Mantis is a bit of wild card
because we haven't seen a lot of her
She is already confirmed for infinity war.
And we know that James Gunn had said that Kurt Russell's Ego the living Planet
character will continue to be very big in the MCU
He will definitely be back for Guardians 3. He might even show in a Thor movie
in the future too. But can we just say how good it is that he is coming back
for Guardians 3. It would have been a complete
disaster for the franchise if he
would have completely left and somebody else would have come on to write the script
There are so few people that have the
deep comic book knowledge and love for comic books
that he has, that also really good writers,
really good producers
and have a really strong, distinct creative vision
for his universe that he has created with these movies
So, given the right amount of time - whatever
he comes up with Guardians 3 - is gonna be a
big slam dunk. Obviously, he changes some things from the comics.
Like Ego the living planet in the movies
is Peter Quill's father. But it is
Jason of Spartax in the comics
You will laugh about this. Kevin Feige actually confirms that
Jason of Spartax does appear during Guardians of the Galaxy volume 2
but not in the way you would expect. He is in the MCU
so it's canonised. But, it's a place instead of a person
So when you go and see the movie, just be on the lookout for that.
I think, I should clear it up, if there is any confusion in the comments -
when he says that the next Guardians movie - Guardians volume 3
will come after infinity war - he is talking about the second infinity war film
which they have already changed the name of.
So, this is going to be after 2019 - firmly in phase 4
They are already booked solid with movies for phase 3 right now
But in terms of stories and character evolution
based on some of the stuff they said about the characters
when they are picking up in Guardians volume 2
you learn a little about the legend of Peter Quill
and the guardians growing in the galaxy
People talk about him being able to hold an infinity stone
That's not a secret
Fact that they defeat Ronan is a big deal
the fact that they saved the galaxy itself
So Peter Quill is slowly becoming more and more of an asshole,
the more famous they get.
So as they build in to the infinity war,
think about what he is going to be like
and his reputation in the galaxy after that
So if you have been reading the comics, you know that there was a
crossover arc with Captain Marvel
character where she went to space,
she had a romance with Peter Quill. But,
for a time he deposed his father
and had absolutely disastrous attempt to  rule the
spartoi empire. So, one way to escalate Guardian's story
would be for Peter Quill to have
to be more of a leader. Because he is a terrible leader.
Can you imagine him solo trying to be the leader of an actual big group of people?
It would be disastrous.
I don't think they will ever get to Realm of Kings or anything like that
Because that gets into a lot of Fox-Xmen characters
unless they change the sharing rights.
But in all the Guardians movies, you have like this really
small runner stories where
Peter Quill meeting his father against
the backdrop of this galactic war
with the Sovereign chasing them down.
So, James Gunn said that with the third movie
they will try to defy
you expectations.
In the way, the second movie is so much bigger and grander
while still being a small movie compared to the first movie
Same thing will be true for the third movie
So it is not like they keep going to get bigger and bigger
the way they did with avengers Movies.
Because that's a recipe for failure
So I feel Rocket and Groot will continue
to be the emotional core of Guardians.
Groot will get bigger depending on how much
time has passed. They said only 2 months has gone by
when the start of Guardians 2 picks up from the last Guardians film
So they have officially broken the Marvel timeline
Things don't move in real time anymore
It used be like if 6 months went by before
the next movie came out, then in the timeline
it will be 6 months later. But now they are jumping around the time a little bit
So that explains why Groot
is still so small.
Kevin Feige that he basically just stepped out of the pot
He still dumb as rocks. Even though
it is going to be a long time before the third guardians movie
comes out. It would be awesome
to go back to his home planet
So, maybe by that time he will have fully grown back to his adult self
Let me know in the comments
what story do you want them to pull from for
Guardians of the Galaxy 3. Just remember that
they don't really do the comic book arcs.
There was a little bit of annihilation conquest
in the first Guardians film because that
was the story how the Guardians come together
- this iteration of Guardians -
so the second movie is even more
off comic book. Even though they are doing a lot of
easter eggs from the comic.
Like Ego the living planet is a huge comic book
character. He is one of the most obscured,
biggest, literally biggest, Marvel villain.
But they haven't really been any big story
where he has been tied to Peter Quill
He is way off book even though he is doing a lot of comic book things
But, I know a lot of people are holding
hope for Venom space night
I am not expecting that. But, that would be
a backdoor for them for integrating
the venom character into the MCU
if they are gonna go that route. There are still
so many questions about the Venom/Spiderman
franchise because Sony has its own
thing going on and it sounds like James Gunn
likes to play in his own sandbox as much as possible
He has gone to great lengths to keep
any other humans from Earth
appearing in his movies and even though
Earth does appear during Guardians 2, he said
that the Guardians themselves do not
travel to Earth the way that Thor travel to Earth in Thor Ragnorok